et on vous le disait en titre après
avoir dévoilé les chiffres de la
délinquence hier la municipalité de tour
à la rencontre des habitants et
commerçants des hall et des chiffres qui
font état d'une très forte baisse par
exemple - 25 % pour les vols depuis
début 2023 et pourtant le sentiment
d'insécurité lui ne faiblit pas au
contraire comme en témoigne plusieurs
pétitions récentes pour réclamer des
actes un ralbol qui s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui lors d'une réunion et
auquelle l'adjoint à la tranquillité
publique a tenté de répondre Fustin lun
dal devant les vitrines présence de
squatter intrusion insultes et autres
incivilité les habitants et commerçan du
quartier desal en ont marre selon eux
ces faits seraient de plus en plus
fréquents depuis 2 ans tous les jours je
subis tous ce tous ces marginau avec
leur trottinettes qui vendent les
drogues qui prennent les drogues sous
les trottinettes et que on voit nos
enfants du quartier moi mes clients qui
sont en train de se dégrader et on doit
rien dire que nous on a eu une intrusion
chez nous il y a 3 mecs à 4h du matin
qui sont sont ont ouvert la porte et qui
sont rentrés dans les immeubles quand
portez plainte que que l'agent qui a
pris votre déposition la prend se lève
et dit désolé on fera rien moi ça m'a
dissuadé d'y retourner la deuxè et la
trè fois pourtant les chiffres ne
suivent pas ce ressenti par rapport à
2022 - 22 % d'atteintte au bien à tour
en revanche plus 5 % d'atteinte aux
personnes mais un chiffre gonflé par les
violences intrafamiliales le direct de
la police municipale ainsi que l'élu à
la sécurité Philippe géger ont écouté
les demandes on va mettre en place un
Conseil de la nuit pour être plus près
des demandes des habitants parce que les
habitants et les commerçants sont
présents dans ce conseil et nous pourons
échanger sur les
possibilités d'action on a besoin de ce
retour à la fois des commerçants à la
fois des habitants parce que souvent les
intérêts sont un tout petit peu
différents les services de police de
devrait aussi mettre l'accent sur le
déménagement des squatters et la
régulation du bruit auprès des bars et
des boîtes de nuit qui ne respectent pas
la réglementation des solutions qui ne
convainquent qu'à moitié je pense qu'on
a eu des échanges intéressants pour
comprendre les situations maintenant je
je dirais ben je demande avoir
l'application concrète des solutions
qu'on nous a apporté parce que
j'aimerais pouvoir dire que je sais pas
d'ici un mois on va dormir on va être
plus apaisé on va être moins virulent
plus serein dans notre quartier le
préfet a également annoncé vouloir
intensifier la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants